قبل ان يغادر لزياره الولايات المتحده جاء
ليودع الجنود في بحدود المدينه الاوكرانيه
التي تقاوم منذ اشهر هجوم الانفصاليين
والجنود الروس ومرتزقه
الى واشنطن علما اوكرانيا كعربون شكر
للامريكيين من قوات بلاده وليطلب المزيد
من السلاح
رئيس الولايات المتحده على الدعم الامريكي
لكن هذه المساعدات غير كافيه كما نرى هنا
منذ بدايه الحرب ومن المقرر ان يلقي
خلالها كلمه امام ممثلي الشعب الامريكي في
الكونجرس وان يلتقي نظيره الامريكي
الخاصه
من الديمقراطيين الى الجمهوريين في
حيث يستعد في هذا الوقت النواب الامريكيون
للتصويت على حزمه جديده من الدعم
لاوكرانيا بقيمه 45 مليار دولار كما
سيصادق جوبايدن اخيرا على ارسال نظام
باتريوت المضاد للطائره الولايات المتحده
اكبر داعم على الاطلاق لاوكرانيا قدمت لها
منذ بدايه الحرب نحو 50 مليار دولار
وامام الاستهداف الروسي المنهج لبنيه
الطاقه في اوكرانيا تريد كيف مزيدا من
السلاح الاعتراض الهجمات الجويه وتقول ان
موسكو حاليا تسعى الى تقويض البنيه
التحتيه الاخرانيه تمهيدا لهجوم الجديد
يتوقعوا ان ياتي من الاراضي البيلاروسيا